Hey everyone, we're going to be taking a look at the gains from trade inside of a non strategic bargain.
And with that what we're talking about is looking at John Nash's axiom here.
So let's go ahead and dive into it.
And we have, formally speaking, we're going to let a be the agreement that is reached, whatever the two parties that come together and decide the price that one will pay and the other will receive D1 and D2.
Here are the disagreement values, that is the outside options that both of these players have.
Now to have positive gains from trade, we have to have the agreement reach minus the disagreement values be greater than zero.
And then when this is achieved and we have John Nash's axiom applied, we say that the gains are split evenly.
Otherwise we don't have a Nash bargaining solution.
That is we don't approach John Nash's axiom.
So we have to have these gains split evenly in order to achieve that.
Now let's take a look at some of the concepts and intuition behind this.
Knowing how to bargain non strategically here is about changing the discriminant value of the player.
So if you have a better outside option, then you lean the bargain more in your favor.
If you want to increase your bargaining power to do this you need to do a few things.
One, increase your disagreement value, get a better outside option.
Two, decrease the other player's disagreement value, so decrease their outside options.
Or three, do a combination of both of those.
So again it's all about changing the outside options that are available to disagreement values that are available for yourself and for the other player inside of the bargain that's taken place.
Now if you do any of these, then we can improve our bargaining position.
So what we're trying to do is, is make it more difficult for the other party in the bargain to have an improved position.
Now if you have the improved position, it allows you to more easily walk away than what the other player may have.
So the other player becomes more accepting to your terms.
So if you think about salary negotiations, if you have outside options, that is if you have a job offer elsewhere, then it becomes more difficult for your for the other party to bargain hard against you because you have the ability to walk away more easily.
So let's take a look at an example here.
And we're going to be looking at buying a used car.
We can haggle a little bit.
We're going to have the value of the car that you place on it at $15,000.
So this is your maximum willingness to pay and the dealer has a value on the car of 10,000.
So this is their minimum willingness to sell.
Okay, the dealer will sell that car at 10,000, but doesn't really want to.
You would buy it at 15,000, but you really don't want to.
You want to do some price lower than 15,000.
The dealer wants to do some price above 10,000.
So here we look at a few scenarios.
One, we're trying to increase our or your disagreement value so we can find a car that's just like the one that we're bargaining for right now for $14,000.
Or we can look at the dealer saying, I got another person coming in willing to buy this car for 16.
So we have two different scenarios here, and we're going to be asking ourselves a few questions.
One, what are the potential gains from a bargain between you and the dealer?
Two, what are the disagreement values?
And then three, what price represents a Nash bargaining solution?
Because remember, the Nash bargaining solution, we're trying to split the gains from trade to get a true Nash bargaining solution.
So let's look at these answers here.
Consumers value $15,000.
This is our maximum willingness to pay or your maximum willingness to pay the dealer's minimum acceptable price.
What they're willing to sell, they don't want to, but they will, is $10,000.
So the maximum consumer surplus, assuming you could get the car at $10,000, would be five grand.
The minimum willingness to pay in scenario one was $14,000.
So potential joint gains from trade at a maximum that is, would be $4,000.
That is the 10,000 up to the $14,000.
So if you have a disagreement value that lowers your willingness to pay from 15,000 to $14,000, and you buy that car at $10,000, the potential joint gains from trade are 10,000, or, excuse me, are $4,000.
The issue with this is it all goes to you.
It doesn't go to the dealer.
Now, if we were to price at $12,000, then 2,000 goes to you, 2,000 goes to the dealer, and that becomes more in line with Nash's bargaining solution.
Look at scenario two, alternative to sell at $16,000, you, the consumer, have a maximum willingness to pay of $15,000.  So guess what?
You're not going to be getting the car, and no deal is going to be made, and there are no potential gains.
Okay, let's look at this a little bit more in depth here.
In the first scenario, again, our disagreement value, the value we get from buying a similar car elsewhere.
So we had a maximum list pay of 15,000.
But we find a car that's very similar to the one that we want to buy from this current dealer for 14,000, meaning we have $1,000 disagreement value.
This is what we can fall back to if we need to tell that first dealer, hey, look, I'm not paying more than 14,000 since I have outside options.
I have a car down the road just like this one here, that I can go purchase for $14,000.
So you create that $1,000 cushion for yourself.
Now, the dealer, on the other hand here, we still have 1,000 that we can fall back on our outside option.
But the dealer now looks at this and goes, I can sell this car for $16,000 to somebody else, and my minimum willingness to sell is $10,000 what it costs to me to have this car.
So I have a $6,000 disagreement value compared to your $1,000 disagreement value.
So the dealer in this case has increased their outside options so they're more willing to sell to somebody who's going to pay the higher price compared to what you are willing to pay that lower price.
But just for the sake of argument, we're going to say that these two are going to get together and they're going to engage in trade, and they're going to have a little bargain.
And in scenario one, we purchase that car for $14,000.
Now, the total surplus that's available, 15,000, minus 10,000.
What our maximum willingness to pay is, minus what the dealer's minimum willingness to sell is, is $5,000.
In this scenario, we get 1,000.
From that 15,000.
Our maximum was to pay, minus our outside option, what we could have done, but we ended up getting the car to 14,000 anyway.
So we get 1,000.
From this, the dealer gets 4,000, what the dealer sold the car for, minus what their minimum willingness to sell was.
So they get 4,000.
This isn't a Nash bargaining solution, since those gains aren't split evenly.
In order to get a Nash bargaining solution, what we should do is instead of having the price be 14,000, the price should be 12,500.
In this case, each party gets 2,500 in surplus.
Now, that's scenario one.
Again, both had outside options, but they came together.
Excuse me, you, player one, had an outside option, which you came together.
You were able to sell the car for 14,000.
You did have a gain from trade, but didn't reach the full Nash bargaining solution.
And the better solution to achieve even gains from trade would have been to have a price be 12,500.
Now, in the Second scenario, there's no deal.
There's just no deal because the dealer has an outside option that's way greater than anything that you're ready to deal with because they can now sell that car for 16,000 versus you have the maximum willingness to pay of only 15,000.
So that brings us to some key takeaways here.
In this bargain, scenario two gave the dealer a much stronger position than what you had.
The buyer thus had a lower opportunity cost, lower disagreement value.
So if the scenario were to play out in real life, what we would have seen is that deal never would have took place because the dealer was in such a better position than the buyer was.
So, but had the dealer had no potential buyers, then what we would have seen is their disagreement value decrease.
And they would have been more willing to accept a deal at 14,000, maybe even lower, just to sell that car because there was surplus to be had in doing so.
Now, had the buyer not had any alternative, then guess what?
They wouldn't have had any disagreement value either.
And so that decreases their bargaining power.
Which brings us to a final point.
Altering our disagreement value is the key to successfully, successfully getting a bargain to work in your favor.
And if you take that knowledge and you apply it to your negotiations, you will have a better bargaining position in them.  And that's it.  Hope you've enjoyed it.